اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
عناوين
المرصد يقول ان الضربه الاسرائيليه في
حماه وطرطوس استهدفت مستودعات سلاح لا
تتبع النظام
[تصفيق]
اسرائيل تعلن مقتل ثلاثه
مخابرات امريكا تحذر من حرب استنزاف يشنها
بوت لارهاق الغرب وتحقيق النصر في
اوكرانيا
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا افاد مدير المصري لحقوق
الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن العربي ان
الغارات الاسرائيليه في حماه
سلاح لا تتبع جيش السوري ودمرت بطاريات
للدفاع الجوي
لان مستودعات للايرانيين الواقعه في جبال
مصياف وطرطوس لانها ضمن بنك اهداف اسرائيل
على ما يبدو داخل التراب السوري اقلهم في
اغار الصباح اليوم جرى تدمير مستودع
للايرانيين يقع في منطقه جبليه متداخله
بين محافظتي حمى وطرطوس اي منطقه غرب
مصياف ادت لتدمير هذا المستودع في الدخان
الذي شاهدناه في تدمير هذا المستودع كان
هناك الصواريخ اخرى استهدفت بعض بطاريات
الدفاع الجوي هناك خمسه اثنان منهم قتلوا
اثنان كانوا من يعني في منطقه المستودع او
مستودع وثلاثه جرحى من القوات النظام في
القصف الاسرائيلي
وكاله الانباء السوريه سانا كانت افادت ان
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه شنت هجوما
جديدا بالصواريخ استهدف بعض المواقع في
منطقه مصياف في حماه ونقلت الوكاله عن
مصدر عسكري قوله ان قصف اسرائيلي استهدف
بعض النقاط في دفاي محافظه تيطرطوس وحماه
مع ادى الى اصابه ثلاثه عسكريين بجروح
ووقوع بعض الخسائر الماديه واكد المقصد ان
وسائل الدفاع الجوي تصدت لهذه الصواريخ
واسقطت بعضها ايضا
[موسيقى]
ويعود الينا من مدينه كومنت البريطانيه
مدير المرصد السوري حقوق الانسان رامي عبد
الرحمن من جديد وهل ما زالت توتر سيد
الموقف في حماه وطرطوس بعد هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه ام ان الامور عندي طبيعتها
الان
العالم يبدو بانها عادت صباح الخير مجددا
عادت الى طبيعتها الان الاستهداف مثل ما
ذكرنا هو لتدمير مستودع حقيقه الامر يقع
في ريف مصياف الغربي المتداخل مع محافظه
طرطوس وايضا هناك كان استهدافات لبطاريات
الدفاع الجوي في محافظه طرطوس
القتيلين هم في المستودع من حراس المستودع
يعني اصبحوا اشياء او لم يعد لديه لهم
اشلاعك ايضا بالاضافه للجرحى من عناصر
قوات النظام بينهم الضابط على الاقل في
اصيبوا باستهداف بطاريه بطاريه للدفاع
الجوي كما تحاول التصدي للاستهداف
الاسرائيلي على الاراضي السوريه الحصيله
حتى اللحظه مثل ما ذكرنا بينهم ثلاثه جرحى
من السوريين اثنان اشلائهم حقيقه الامر ان
وجدت في مصياف في غرب مصياف في تدمير
المستودع وهذا المستودع او منطقه المستودع
كان فيها مستودع سابقا دمر بشكل كامل في
الخامس والعشرين من شهر اغسطس الفائت وكان
فيه
مستواريخ الايرانيه او التي جرى تصنيعها
وتجميعها في منطقه البحوث العلميه في
مصياف وجمع تخزينها في هذه الجبال السوريه
نتحدث عن غارات متكرره في مناطق السوريه
مختلفه وفي يعني فارق زمني بسيط
انها تحدث كنا عن مطار حلب قبل ايام نتحدث
اليوم عن حماه وطرطوس سنتحدث ايضا قبل
يومين عن دير الزور هل يعني ذلك ان هناك
تحركات
ضد المصالح الاسرائيليه كما يقول
الاسرائيليون في هذه المناطق تسعد او تمشي
في او في وتيره متزايده هذه الايام
يعني مصالح لا يعني مصالح العام الفاعل
كان هناك اسنان وثلاثون استهداف للاراضي
السوريه جرت تدمير 21 هدف يعني من الاراضي
السوريه كامل التراب السوري
المعركه هي مستمره او القتال هو مستمره
على الاراضي السوريه اسرائيل تستهدف هذه
المستودعات داخل التراب السوري وايضا دعم
نتحدث واقعيه بان السلاح موجود يعني
السلاح موجود ويدخل بشكل مستمر ويخزن داخل
الاراضي السوريه شاهدنا بانها على المعبر
منطقه معبر البوكمال حزب الله اللبناني
مثلما نشرنا يوم امس واعاد انتشاره في تلك
البقع من الجغرافيا السوريه حزب الله
لبناني موجود عند الحدود السوريه
اللبنانيه اي ان هناك صراع بين هذه
الاطراف على التراب السوري وعلى حساب
السياده السوريه والعزاب ابناء الشعب
السوري منكم انت بريطانيه
حقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن شكرا جزيلا
لك
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه
فلسطينيين غرب بل خلال اشتباكات غربيه
نابلس ووقع تبادل لاطلاق النار بين القوات
الاسرائيليه وفلسطينيين في منطقه عسكريه
خاضعه للسيطره الامنيه الاسرائيليه بالقرب
من نابلس الشماليه ضفه الغربيه ومنذ بدايه
العام الجاري ادى تصعيده بين فلسطين
والاسرائيليين الى مقتل اكثر من 80
فلسطينيا بحسب بيانات رسميه هذا ونشر
الجيش الاسرائيلي صورا لاسلحه للاسلحه
الفلسطينيه او لاسلحه الفلسطينيين الثلاثه
الذين قتلوا بعد ان اطلقوا النار على قوه
داخل موقع عسكري في مفرق جيت واوضح
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي اوضح في
تغريده على حسابه في تويتر ان قوه عسكريه
قامت باطلاق النار صوب المسلحين مؤكدا ان
القوات الاسرائيليه تمكنت من تحديد ثلاثه
منهم خلال تبادل لاطلاق نار بالاضافه الى
مسلح اخر سلم نفسه للقوات وتم اعتقاله
هذا وتظاهر عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين
الاسبوع العاشر على التوالي احتجاجا على
خطه تغيير النظام القضائي التي تحاول
الحكومه اقراها وتشير تقارير الى مشاركه
نحو 300 الف متظاهر في تل ابيب حيث المقر
الرئيسي لهذه المظاهرات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نشاطنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل تقرير
بريطانيه
في تركيا
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد وجه اكثر من
140 ناشطا سياسيا ومدنيا ايرانيا رساله
الى الامين العام المتحده طالب فيها
بتحقيق فوري في تسميم التلميذات لبلادهم
وكانت الداخليه الايرانيه اعلنت القبض على
اكثر من 100 شخص للاشتباه بتوارقهم في
قضيه تصميم طلاب المدارس في البلاد وافاد
بيان الداخلي ان من بين المعتقلين اشخاصا
لديهم دوافع اعدائيه هدفها بث الرعب في
نفوس الناس والطلاب واغلاق المدارس واثاره
الشكوك وان المهتمين بل المتهمين اتخذوا
خطوات مثل استخدام مواد كريهه الرائحه
لكنها غير ظهره من جهاته استنكر رئيس
الايراني الاسبق الاصلاحي محمد خاتمي
حوادث التسميم الطالبات الايرانيات معتبرا
انها جرائم فظيعه ولا تغتفر كما استنكر
تعامل مسؤول البلد مع هذه الحوادث وقال
خاتمي انه ينبغي قطع الايدي الملوثه التي
ارتكبت مثل هذه الاعمال الاجراميه عن قصد
او بتحريض من الغير واقتلاع جذور هذه
الحوا وطمانه المجتمع بان مثل هذه الحوادث
لن يتم التسامح معها باي شكل من الاشكال
قتل خمسه اشخاص واصيب ثلاثه منفجار في
مبنى سكني بمدينه تبريز الايرانيه وذكر
مسؤول الطوارئ ان الانفجار ادى لتدمير
ثلاثه منازل ولم يتم تحديد طبيعته حتى
الان
وقعت المفوضيه الرئه المفوضه الرئاسيه
لحقوق الاطفال لدى روسيا ماريال على وثيقه
تسلمت بموجبها 49 طفلا يتيما من افراد
عائله مقاتل تنظيم داعش من ممثلين عن
اداره الذاتيه الكرديه في شمال شرق سوريا
وتتراوح اعمار الاطفال بين خمسه وخمسه عشر
عاما وجميعهم كانوا موجودين في مخيمي روج
والهول الذين تديرهم الاداره الذاتي في
شمال شرق سوريا ويؤويان عشرات الالاف
بينهم افراد من عائلات مقاتل داعش
[موسيقى]
اعلان المتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في
شرق البلاد ان 2021 من قوات الموالي
لموسكو قتلوا واصيب اكثر من 300 خلال 24
ساعه في معركه مدينه فيما اعلنت وزاره في
الدفاع الروسيه انما يصل الى 210 جنود
اوكرانيين قتلوا في الجزء الذي يمثل خط
المواجهه الاوسع نطاقا
ومع احتدام المعارك للسيطره على اباحموت
نشر الحرس الاوكراني مقطعا من داخل احد
مصانع المدينه يوفق بعضا من المعارك التي
جرت مع عناصر من مجموعه فاجنر التي تشكل
راس الحربه بل حربه القتال الجاري وفق
الحرس الاوكراني فان الروسي حاولوا التحصن
فيه الا ان القوات الاوكرانيه باغثتهم
وشنت هجوم مضاده عليهم اسفر عن مقتل سته
جنود روسيا داخل المصنع بمدافع بمدافع على
الشاشه بدورها على هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه تصدي الاثنين وتسعين هجوما
روسيا في خمس اتجاهات والخمسه اتجاهات
خلال 24
وقالت في بيانها اليومي ان الضبع صاروخيه
الروسي استهدفت البنيه التحتيه في مدينه
خرسون واسفرت عن مقتل مدنيين اثنين واصابه
اخرين والاصابه اخرين واضافت ان الهدف
الرئيسي للضربات الروسيه خلال اليوم
الماضي هو الوصول الى الحدود الاداريه
لمنطقه
وتطوير الهجوم على طول خط المواجهه في
نشرت قوه الروسيه مقاطع مصوره للجبهه
الجنوبيه في مدينه سباح واظهرت الصور
دمارا كبيرا بينما اشارت قوات فاغنر الى
ان استخدام القوه الناريه تدميريه يعود
الى ملاحقه المجموعات الصغيره من القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تحصنت في المنازل واشارت
قوات فارغنر الى ان الجبهه الجنوبيه في
بخموت اصبحت بالكامل تحت سيطرتها
مشاهدينا ينضمون الملكيه والصحفي محمد
البابا اهلا بك معنا في هذه النشره وبدايه
هل صحيح ان القوات الاوكرانيه فقدت قدرا
كبيرا من سيطرتها على المنطقه الشرقيه
والجنوبيه
لبخموت ماذا تقول الروايه الاوكرانيه حول
ذلك
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه تؤكد ان قواتها منتشره في وسط
وشمالي وجنوب وغرب مدينه باخمت باستثناء
الاحياء او باستثناء المنطقه التي تقع شرق
نهر
هذه المنطقه التي انسحبت منها القوات
الاوكرانيه بعد ان تم تدمير جميع المنازل
التي تقع في تلك المنطقه وهي عباره عن
منطقه سكنيه ذو منازل صغيره الحجم تم
تدميرها بفعل تبادل والقاصه المدفعي بين
الطرفين خلال الاسبوعين او ثلاثه اسابيع
الماضيه ودخلتها يعني قبل ثلاثه ايام قوات
فارغني سيطرت على تلك المنطقه والان هذه
المنطقه تعتبر مثل يعني
مكان الاستنزاف قوات الجيش الاوكراني
والهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه صباح هذا
اليوم اعلنت ان خسائر القوات الروسيه يعني
خلال هذه السنه سنه وشهر من الحرب تجاوزت
159 الف جندي روسي قتلوا على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بينهم وخمسه وتسعين جندي فقط
بالامس وخاصه يعني بحسب تقارير خاصه للجيش
الاوكراني من مساء الامس حتى ساعات الصباح
الاولى خسرت القوات الروسيه العشرات من
القوات العشرات بعد استهداف مدفع عنيف
للقوات الاوكرانيه بعد ان حصلت القوات
الاوكرانيه على جزء من ذخائر كانت تريد
الحصول عليها من الشركاء الغربيين بدات
تستعملوها بالامس وكما تقول يعني الروايه
الروسيه هذه الذخائر هي ذخائر حلف الناتو
تدك مراكز الجيش الروسي في المنطقه
الشرقيه وفي المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه
لمدينه اشتباكات عنيفه ليله امس ايضا
للمره الثالثه يعني خلال 24 ساعه عاد
اندريه وهو قائد القوات البريه للجيش
الاوكراني عاد الى مدينه باخمت وقاده
اجتماع لتثبيت خطوط الدفاعيه للجيش
الاوكراني خلال الفتره المقبله وللتمهيد
لان اوكرانيا بدات تحشر اكثر من 70 الف في
محيط ضخمه وفي منطقه يعني بين اليمن
والسيفرس على طول هذا الخط تستعد للقوات
الاوكرانيه للقيام بهجوم مضاد خلال الفتره
المقبله لتحرير تلك المنطقه وبدا الهجوم
على مقاطعه مع الحديث عن هذا الهجوم
المضاد هناك حديث ايضا عن خلافات كبيره
رشحت بين الوزير وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
وايضا الرئيسكي
تاثيرات واضحه لهذه الخلافات على المشهد
الاوكراني وانعكاس ايضا على المشهد
العسكري تحديدا محمد بالفعل يعني هذا
الحديث كان يتداول ولكن جاءت الرسائل
ايجابيه خاصه قبل امس يعني الرئيس
الاوكراني شارك في تابين احد قاده
الميدانيين ديفينشي الذي قتل في مدينه كان
له قبل امس يوم الجمعه كان هناك تابين
كبير في وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف شارك
فيه وزير الدفاع والرئيس زلينسكي وتبادلوا
الاحاديث حول طبيعه المعارك يعني الرئيس
في خلال الفتره الماضيه اكد تمسكه
والعلاقه الوطيده مع وزير الدفاع وايضا ما
يتداول يعني كل هذه هي اخبار واشاعات ولا
يوجد اي خلاف بينما ايضا يعني اذيع قبل
حوالي اسبوع عبر الدعايه الروسيه كما تصف
هنا العلامه الاوكرانيه ان هناك خلاف بين
قائد الجيش الاوكراني فاليري والرئيس
الاوكراني حول تمسك الرئيس بقرار الدفاع
عنه ولكن جاءت يعني المعلومات يعني تقارير
من القصر الرئاسي ان هناك وحده بين الجميع
والجميع هم فريق واحد والرئيس الاوكراني
متمسك بجميع القاده خاصه وزير الدفاع يعني
وزير دفاعه قائد القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه فاليري وحتى الاكسي وهو يعني
امين عام مجلس الامن والدفاع الاعلى
الاوكراني وهذه المجموعه هي تسمى يعني
اراد المجلس الحربي في اوكرانيا وهي التي
تقوم بدراسه اوضاع المعارك واتخاذ
القرارات الرئيسيه حول الانسحاب او او
اعلان هجوم او اي شيء يتعلق بالعمليات
العسكريه ولا وجود يعني بحسب مصادر في
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه لا وجود لاي خلاف
بين القياده الرئاسيه والقياده العسكريه
من نوع اخر وهو بين فاجنر وبين
قائد القوات الروسيه او الدوازات الدفاع
الروسيه شكرا لك محمد البابا شكرا شكرا
وهذا ما سنتابعه مشاهدينا في هذا التقرير
وفي ظل التزايد التوتر بين قائد مجموعه
فاجن
انكشفت التقارير اعلامي امريكيه عن وجود
رغبه لدى بعض المسؤولين الروس في كبح جماح
بريكوجين خاصه بعد تاخره في انجاز المهمه
بسيطره على نتابعه
المقاتلون يسالونني لماذا التاخير في
امدادات الذخيره التي تعهدت بها وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في موسكو
وايضا لماذا لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد عناصر
الجدد
بالتصريحات المعتقده بين انه لم يكمل
مهمته بعد في بخموت عدم رضا الكرملين على
بريكوجين دفعه الى توبيخه بطريقه غير
مباشره اذ لم تتم دعوته لحضور خطاب بوتين
في الذكرى السنويه الاولى لانطلاق العمليه
العسكريه كما تم منع ممثليه من دخول مقر
القياده العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا في
المقابل بدا مستعدا للمواجهه مع الكريم
حيث اشتكى علانيه من عدم حصول قوته على
الاسلحه والذخيره وعدم السماح له بتجنيد
عناصر اضافيه لكن السؤال المطروح الان كيف
سيتعامل الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مع
هذه المواجهه بين بريكوجين والكريملين
فحسب مصادر صحيفه ويسترن جورنال فان بوتين
قرر كبح جماح رئيس فاغنر لكن مسؤولا
استخباراتيا اوروبيا قال ان بريكوجين سيظل
في منصبه طالما ان روسيا بحاجه اليها او
بالاحرى طالما ان المعارك بحاجه الى
مقاتله وسام الذهبي العربيه
استنكر رئيس الاوكرانيزيا بالهجمات
الروسيه الجديده على خرسون وزابوريجيا
والمناطق الحدوديه الاوكرانيه
مشدد ان روسيا اصبحت
مرادفا للارهاب وستكون مثالا للهزيمه
والعقاب العادي على ارهابها لا يمكن وقف
العقوبه
اودى القصف الروسي بحياه الناس في خرسون
وقتل ثلاثه اوكرانيين
وفي زابوريا اصاب صاروخ روسي منشاه بنيه
تحتيه حيويه بالمدينه
وعبر المناطق الحدوديه قصف الغزاه الروس
القرى لتخويف الناس وطردهم روسيا اصبحت
مرادفا للارهاب
وستكون مثالا للهزيمه والعقاب العادل على
هذا الارهاب وهذا العقاب لا يستطيع
الكرملين ايقافه
حذر مدير وكاله المخابرات الامريكيهنز من
حرب استنزاف طاحنه سيمضي فيها الرئيس
الروسي
او ليكسب الحرب في اوكرانيا حتى لو اضطر
الامر لزحقهم دون الاقتراث للدع الغربي
المؤيده على انه بهذه الطريقه قد ينتصر
مشددا على انه وبالرغم من كل العقوبات
التي تواجه القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
الا ان بوتين متفرق لهذه الحرب ويتخذ نظره
بعيده المدى على حد وصفه وفي سياق متصله
هو سفير امريكي سابق في روسيا ستوازن
التاثير الاقتصادي اذا اختار تسليح موسكو
حيث قد تحرم من الوصول الى السوق
الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
من موسكو مشاهدينا ينضم الى نادي
الدبلوماسي الروسي السابع اهلا بك معنا في
هذه النشره ما هي قراءتك لتصريحات بيرز
وهل تحولت الحرب فعلا الى حرب استنزاف بين
موسكو والغرب
بالفعل هذا الحرب اصبحت اكثر من الضروري
الى ان في هل خلال هذا الحرق يموت الناس
من جهتين من جهه اوكرانيه هناك كذلك الروس
ومن روسيا كذلك الروس وانا اتذكر في هذه
الحاله الاحد النقاط بين العسكريين
القدامى عندما كان سوارا في يقاتل الاتراك
في حرب تركيا الروسيه احد قاده الميدان
كان يعمل له تقرير كم عاده قتله بين
الاتراك قال قائد
الميدان انه هذا علف جندي تركي قتل
وسرور قالوا
لماذا انت
شو انت
تعتبر فقط
عشره الاف
لتلك المجموعه
التي تقاتل لوحدها
لذلك استسلام هو شغلات ليس جيش الروسي فقط
مجموعه
ولكن
هذا مهمه المعارك ان يستخرجوا ان
القوات الاحتياطات الجيش الاوكراني في
منطقه كيف نحن نعمل نعرف جيدا ان هناك
استعدادات تحت تشجيع خبراء الامريكان يقتل
تقطلات الجيش الاوكراني يهيئون لهجوم على
باتجاه ماريوبال يتحضرون لهجوم المعاكس
لكن في ذات التوقيت هناك خلافات كبيره
اشرت اليها الان ربما بين بريكوجين وقالت
الجيش او قللت منها حقيقه لكن المصادر
الغربيه تتحدث عن ان الج الغربيه تتحدث عن
ان القياده الروسيه ربما اتسعا للتخلص
منها منزعج جدا من تصرفاته
هذا الكلام مسرحيه لحتى يقنع
اوكرانيين ان الروس الضعفه انا لا تعالوا
الى هون الى محمود
نقاتل نحو ولذلك هذا لكي يستخرج القوات
الاحتياط في زبولوجيا المستعده لهجوم
لذلك انا استسلم 100% ان بريجوجين كاحد
مغليين
يتمرد ضد كريم هذا مستحيل تماما
ولذلك هو احد من ادمن الناس
تحت حمايه
سمعته من قبل كريملين شكرا لك
اظهر مقطع فيديو عن المعارك الجاريه في
اوكرانيا كيف تمكنت القوات الدفاعيه
الاوكرانيه من القضاء على صواريخ بوك ارض
جو الروسيه في منطقه
مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل البرهان نائبه
يقرران تشكيل لجنه مشتركه لمتابعه الاوضاع
الامنيه في السودان منذ التوتر الاخير
[موسيقى]
المرصد يقول ان ضربه الاسرائيليه في حماوه
طرطوس استهدفت مستودعات سلاح لا تتبع
النظام
[تصفيق]
اسرائيل تعلن مقتل ثلاثه
امريكا تحذر من حرب استنزاف يشنها بوت
لارهاق الغرب وتحقيق النصر باوكرانيا
ويقول انه عرض عائلته للخطر خلال اقتحام
الكابيتول
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في السودان وفي
اول اجتماع له ما بعد تفجر الخلافات
بينهما قرر عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي ونائبه محمد حمدانو
تشكيل اللجنه امنيه مشتركه من قوات
النظاميه واجهزه الدوله والحركات المسلحه
لمتابعه الاواعي الامنيه في البلاد كما
اكلت مصادر العربيه ان لقاء جمع رئيس مجلس
السياده ونائبه من جهه والقوى الموقعه
لاتفاق الاطار من جهه اخرى وهو اول لقاء
بين هذه الاطراف عقب التوترات الاخيره
وبعث الاجتماع تسريع الاتفاق وازاله
العقبات التي تعترض الاتفاق الايطالي
اضافه لبحث التصعيد بين الجيش والدعم
السريع الذي اعقب للتصريحات الاخيره بين
قادته
بعد سلسله من التصريحات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تتراوح بين التحذير والتهديد يا
بيان القوات المسلحه مؤكدا على التزامهم
بالاتفاق لطري وحرصهم على حكومه مدنيه
وساخرا من المزايدين على مواقف الجيش تؤكد
قواتكم المسلحه وقيادتها
التزامها التام بمجرات العمليه السياسيه
الجاريه
والتقيد الصارم والتام بما تم التوافق
عليه في الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يفضي الى
توحيد المنظومه العسكريه
وقيام حكومه بقياده مدنيه فيما تبقى من
المرحله الانتقاليه
قوات الدعم السريع ترى ان اساس الخلاف بين
من يريدون تسليم السلطه للمدنيين وبين
الذين يتمسكون بعدم ترك الحكم نافيه
خلافها مع القوات المسلحه
ما في مشكله بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مشكله بين الناس المكرسين بالسلطه الناس
اللي قاعدين مكنكشين والناس الدارين
يسلموا السلطه للحكومه المدنيه
في الوقت الذي تتصاعد فيه اجواء التوتر
واصدم مخاوف من انزلاق للمواجهه يقلل
الخبراء من هذا الخلاف العسكري الخلاف
العسكري العسكري الذي برز في الساحه
بالايام الماضيه وخلاف مجمل سياسي وخرج
الى الهواء الطلق من خلال التصريحات ولم
يصل الى القواعد العسكريه سواء كان في
القوات المسلحه او الدعم السريع وفي تقدير
مثل ما بدا صراع سياسي سينتهي صراع سياسي
هذا الصراع السياسي يمكن ان يقرا في طريقه
تنفيذ الاتفاق الايطالي واداره الفتره
الانتقاليه مساله الدمج الجيوش هي واحده
من المقلقات المقاوف بين الرجلين فالحل
ينبغي ان يكون هو الحوار الشفاف واخراج
الهواء الساخن ووضع الحلول التي لا تبدي
الى تعزيمها التصعيد العسكري وهذا ما لا
يتمناه الجميع خلال الفتره المقبله
الاوضاعوا في الشوارع تبدو طبيعيه هادئه
فيما تتحدث تقارير عن توتر مكتوم بين
الجيش والدعم السريع ما دفع الكثير من
القوى السياسيه لابداء القلق على البلاد
سالم الهاشمي العربي الخرطوم ومن الخرطوم
مشاهدينا يبقى معنا مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم وقبل الحديث سالم عن
هذا الاجتماع بين دقلو والبرهان وبقيه
الاطيه السياسيه دعنا
نتحدث عن الاخبار المتداوله حول انتشار
امني مكثف في العاصمه الخرطوم وسط مخاوف
من اندلاع اشتباكات مسلحه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
صباح الخير احمد وصباح الخير على كل
المشاهدين في البدء الاوضاع الان الطبيعيه
تماما الحركه تكون طبيعيه اكثر من طبيعيه
حتى ازدحام في الشوارع ولا يوجد اي انتشار
لاي قوات امنيه على الشوارع بعكس ما يتم
تداوله في بعض الوسائط وهي اخبار غير
صحيحه على الاطلاق الان على ارض الواقع لا
توجد اي مظاهر امنيه ولا مظاهر عسكريه ولا
وضع طبيعيه في المدن الثلاث في الخرطوم
واندرمان وبحري هذا الاجتماع جاء عشيه امس
بعد بيان الجيش عشيه بيان الجيش الذي بدا
فيه هذا البيان ساخرا من من يزايدونه على
القوات المسلحه
وتضامنه مع الشعب واثبتت واثبت هذا البيان
ان الجيش مع موقفه في الاتفاق الايطالي
وتشكيل الحكومه مدنيه ثم تم تداول العديد
من الاخبار عشيه امس قبل ان ياتي هذا
الاجتماع
ليغلق كل تلك الملفات ويبدا ملفا وهو ان
الرجلين قد قرر القيام بلجنه امنيه مشتركه
هذه اللجنه ستضم قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
والشرطه وكذلك الحركات المقععه الاتفاق
على اتفاق السلام وحتى ايضا سيكون فيها
جهاز الامن والمخابرات تم النقاش في
الاجتماع على مساله مهمه جدا يرى كثير من
المحللين والمتابعين انها هي مربط الفرس
في الخلاف بين الرجلين وهي الورشه التي
ستنعقد عن الاصلاح الامني والعسكري هذه
الورشه لم يحدد لها زمن حتى الان لكن وجود
قوى الحريه والتغيير بالامس او بصوره ادق
وجود القوى الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي
في اجتماع الامس يؤكد انه تم النقاش في
هذه المساله وانه تم الوصول الى نقاط
رئيسيه في الاتفاق بين الرجلين وبين القوى
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي هل تلعب هذه
القوه الموقعه لاتفاق الايطالي هل تلعب
دور الوسيط بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
هذه الازمه السالم
بالحديث عن الوسط احمد الوساطه كانت بين
الوساطه قامت بها مجموعه من الاطراف في
ابرزها من القوى السياسيه القوى المتوقعه
للاتفاق الايطالي كذلك ادارات اهليه وحتى
القوات امنيه وعسكريه او قاده في القوات
الامنيه والعسكريه ايضا قادوا هذه الوساطه
الوساطه كانت مشتركه بين الجميع لحل
الازمه خاصه بعد التداول والتراشق الذي تم
بين قاده قوات الدعم السريع وقاده الجيش
هذا التراشق الذي اخذ فتره من الزمن ايام
في الايام الماضيه ظل الكثير يحذر من ان
هذا التراشق قد يؤدي الى مواجهه وان
المواجهه ليست في مصلحه احد وانه يجب ان
يتحلل الجميع بالحكمه والصبر والاجتماع
للحوار في النقاط التي يكون عليها الخلاف
خاصه فيما يتعلق بهذه الورشه التي ذكرتها
لك احمد وهي ورشه اصلاح الاجهزه الامنيه
العسكريه اخذ اخر الورش التي ستنعقد فيما
يتعلق بالعمليه السياسيه الجاريه الان بال
بدات الورشه الرابعه وهي ورشه العداله
والعداله الانتقاليه وستستمر وسترفع
توصياتها لكن الورشه التي تخص الاجهزه
الامنيه والعسكريه هي ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري وهي مختصه بالاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه شكرا لك من الخرطوم كنت معنا
مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي تحيه سالم
قال المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا انه سيتم
اختيار فريق رفيع المستوى من قبل ليبيين
يتولى العمل على وضع اسس اجراء الانتخابات
العامه هذا العام واضاف باتيلي في مؤتمر
الصحفي في طرابلس انه يمكن وضع خارطه واضح
الانتخابات بحلول منتصف شهر يونيو المقبل
نتابع تباينت الردود الفعل حول الخطط التي
اعلنها المبعوث الدولي الى ليبيا عبد الله
باتيلي والتي ترمي الى جراء الانتخابات
بنهايه العام الحالي بين مؤيد ومعارض وبين
من يضع شروطا للموافقه لانجاح الخطه
فالجنه رفيعه المستوى التي اعلنت تشكيلها
اعترض اكثر من 50 حزبا على عدم اشراك
الاحزاب السياسيه فيها والاكتفاء باجسام
اخرى كيف يمكن ان يكون
استبعاد الاجسام الرئيسيه وهي الاحزاب
السياسيه في عمل سياسي مقبل في ليبيا
وهي يجب ان تكون هي الاساس في هذا العمل
بينما ادخل او ذكر او عدد مكونات اخرى في
داخل هذه
اللجنه رفيعه المستوى بما يرى مرشحون
مستقلون ان الخطه رغم ضعف بعض جوانبها
المتعلقه بالجدول الزمني ولكنها فرصه
لتحريك المياه السياسيه الراكده هي فرصه
ذهبيه لكل من التهم بانه هو
اجل الانتخابات او عرقا هذه العجله
الانتخابيه
فاعتقد انها فرصه من ذهب لاعاده محور
الانتخاب من جديد وفتح الترشح والوصول بنا
الى الانتخابات باذن الله من جانبه اعتبر
رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد
دبيبه ان مطرحه المبعوث الدولي يتوافق مع
رؤيته للحل لما اعترض اعضائه من مجلسي
النواب والدوله على بعض ما جاء في الخطه
اما الشارع الليبي فواجه الخطط المعلنه
بعدم كثيرات واضح اذ يعتبرها عمليه مكرره
ولن تغير بالواقع السياسي القائم
الانتخابات طبعا مطلب كل الليبين ونتمنى
ان تتحقق نتمنى من هذه المبادره ان ترى
النور في قريب العاشر ان شاء الله بصراحه
الحوارات
تصير والحاجه الوحيده فيها ان القائمين
عليها هدفهم الوحيد انه يقعدوا في السلطه
وخلاص اكثر من مليونين مواطنين في قوائم
الناخبين قبل عام من الان في رساله واضحه
منهم لرغبتهم في تغيير الاجسام الموجوده
فهل سينجح السنغالي عبد الله بتليه في
تحقيق طموحهم عبر خطتهم التي اعلنها منير
الاشهب طرابلس العربيه
اكد بيان للخارجيه الايرانيه بان حكومه
الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي خطط خطوه مهمه فيما
يتعلق بالدبلوماسيه الخارجيه للبلاد وذلك
تعليق على الاتفاق على عوده العلقات مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واشارت الخارج
الايراني الى ان الاتفاق سيعود ايجابا
وسيسهم في تامين المصالح المشتركه للشعبين
كما اكدت الخارجيه الايرانيه اكلت ان
الحكومه اتخذت قرارا جدا في مسار تامين
مصالح الشعب الايراني وكذلك شعوب المنطقه
حذر رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال اللبنانيه
نجيب ميقاتي من ان بلاده لا تستطيع تحمل
الازمه السياسيه والشغل الرئاسي طويلا
واشار في تصريحات لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط ان
ازمه في لبنان ليست والده اللحظه وانه يجب
الاسراع في انتخاب رئيس جديد وتشكيل حكومه
جديده
سدد ميقات على انه لا خيار امام لبنان سوى
القيام باصلاحات المطلوبه والتعاون مع
صندوق النقد الدولي لاستقطاب الدعم الدولي
مشاهدينا ذكر تقرير بريطاني ان عملاء
النظام الايراني يقومون بخطف وقتل
اللاجئين السياسيين ايرانيين في تركيا
ورصدت تقرير روايات من مختلف طالب اللجوء
الايرانيين حول مؤامره النظام الايراني
ضدهم اثناء سفرهم الى مدن اخرى في تركيا
وقال عضو سابق في البحريه الايرانيه ان
عملاء النظام حاولوا خطافه بالقرب من
منزله واعتقلت الشرطه التركيه احد عشر
شخصا في هذا الصدد كما افاد متظاهر فقد
بصره بعد اصابته برصاصه في عينه من قبل
القوات القمعيه في اكتوبر الماضي واصبح
لاجئا في تركيا افاد بانه تلقى تهديدات
بالقتل من عملاء النظام الايراني مشيرا
الى انه خلال هذه الفتره الاخيره بات يعيش
سرا في تركيا وانه قطع الاتصال بالجميع
باستثناء عدد قليل من الاشخاص موضحا انه
يجب عليه مغادره تركيا فورا لانه اصبح من
السهل جدا على النظام الايراني خطف وقتل
المعارضين في تركيا
سجلت جهات مختلفه في فرنسا تراجعا في
اعداد المشاركين في التظاهرات الرافضه
لاصلاح نظام التقاعد فيما دعت النقابات
الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون الى استشاره الشعب
وكان هذا اليوم السابع من التعبئه منذ
التاسع عشر من يناير في ظل اضطرابات
مستمره منذ الثلاثاء الماضي وتامل الحكومه
في اقار الاصلاح بشكل نهائي في البرلمان
ويعارض الفرنسيون بغربيتهم بحسب استطلاعات
الراي المشروع الذي يقترح رفع سن التقاعد
من 62 عاما الى اربعه وستين معتبرين انه
غير عادل لا سيما للنساء وذوي المهن الشقه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
موجه سابعه من الاحتجاج شهدتها فرنسا ضد
مساء الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
ترى فقط الاحتجاجات مع اضراب شهدته قطاعات
ابرزها الطاقه والنقل حيث تم الغاء 20% من
الرحلات الجويه
ماكرون يقوم بفعل كل شيء ضدنا وفي المقابل
يعيش حياته بكل رفاهيه الهدوء الذي حافظ
عليه المتظاهرون مع انطلاق الموكب الفارسي
سرعان ما تحول الى مواجهات مع الشرطه بضع
مئات من شبان اليسار العنيفين اشتبكوا مع
عناصر الشرطه عند محاولتهم تحطيم واجهات
مصارف وشركات يقولون انها تمثل راس ماليه
مسؤوله عن ترد اوضاعهم الاشتباكات اوقعت
بعض الاصابات وسمحت للشرطه باجراء عمليات
اعتقال عنيفه وثقتها كاميرا العربيه
سريعا سيطرت الشرطه على الوضع وعاد الهدوء
الى تظاهره لم تقتصر المشاركه بها على
شريحه الموظفين او كبار السن بل ايضا شهدت
مشاركه شبابيه واسعه
مازلت صغير السن لكن هذا الاحتجاج يخص
الجميع انها فرصه تاريخيه لاثبات ان الشعب
في الشارع ولديه اهتمامات لا تتطابق مع
مدراء الشركات والمسؤولين ولديه النيه في
قلب الطاوله واستعاده السلطه حول العمل في
حصيله هذا اليوم اعلنت النقابات عن مشاركه
ثلاثمئه الف في الموكب الباريسي رقم قالت
الشرطه انه مبالغ به واعلنت انها احصت 48
الفرنسي وحكومته على عامل الوقت لانهاك
الحركه الاحتجاجيه لكن المتظاهرين يبدون
استعدادهم للذهاب بعيدا مهما كلف الامر
فديده العربيه باريس قال مايك نائب رئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بين التاريخ
سيحاسب السابق على دوري في الهجوم على
يناير 2020 مضيفا عرض حياه عائلته للخطر
موجها بذلك احد اشد الانتقادات للترامب
حتى الان
دعت نقابه فيرني للعاملين في قطاع الخدمات
في المانيا دعت الى تنظيم اضرابات تحذيريه
اليوم كامل بعد غد الاثنين في العديد من
المطارات الالمانيه في هامبورج وهانوفر
وبريمين بالاضافه الى مطار العاصمه
الالمانيه برلين وافاد توقعات بيانات
اتحاد المطارات بان عدد الرحلات التي سيتم
الغائها وفقا للوضع الحالي يبلغ
351 رحله وعدد الركاب المتاثرين يبلغ خمسه
واربعين الف شخص وقال الاتحاد انه من ان
يصل اجمالي جعاد الركاب المتاثرين
بالاضرابات الى قرابه 100 الف شخص
يتوجه رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الولايات
المتحده اليوم لقاء الرئيس الامريكي ورئيس
الوزراء الاسترالي انتونيز من اجل
الانتهاء من تفاصيل صفقه الغواصه النوويه
التي تهدف الى تصدي للصين وتاتي هذه
الزياره في اطار التحالف اوكس الثلاثي
الذي اعلن عنه في 2021 في اطار الجهود
لمواجهه الوجود العسكري المتنامي للصين في
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وينص اتفاق
اكس ايضا على التعاون بين حلفاء الثلاثه
في مجال الصواريخ الفرد الصوتيه والذكاء
الاصطناعي والحرب الالكترونيه
وافق المجلس الوطني لنواب الشعب الصيني
اعلى هيئه تشريعيه في البلاد على تعيين
الجنرال لشانغ فو في منصبه وزير الدفاع
يخضع لعقوبات امريكيه منذ العام 2018 حيث
تتهمه واشنطن بالتعاون العسكري مع روسيا
فقد كان اطراء في ذلك الوقت اداره التدريب
والتموين بالمجلس العسكري المركزي الصيني
ويرى مراقبون ان هذا الامر قد يجعل
الاتصالات بين واشنطن وبيكيين في المجال
العسكري محرجه وقد تشهد توترات في عهد
وزير الدفاع الصيني الجديد
مشاهدينا قررت كوريا الشماليه اتخاذ
اجراءات مهمه وعمليه وعمليه لردع الحروب
وذلك خلال اجتماع اللجنه العسكريه للحزب
الحاكم برئاسه الزعيم كيم جونغ اون حسب ما
اعلنت وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه
وكانت الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
اعلنتائج راء مناورات عسكريه مشتركه كبيره
من المقرر ان تبدا يوم غد الاثنين الامر
الذي اثار غضب كوريا الشماليه
عاد اربعه رواد فضاء من محطه الفضاء الى
الارض بعد رحله سريعه بعد ان هبطت كبسوله
الفضاء دراغون في خليج المكسيك قباله ساحل
هوردا بالقرب من تامبا وكانت طاقم
الامريكي الروسي الياباني امضى خمسه اشهر
في محطه الفضاء الدوليه التي وصلها في
اكتوبر الماضي في مهمه علميه بقياده نيكول
مان من وكاله ناسا وهي اول امراه امريكيه
من السكان الاصليين تطير الى الفضاء
وفي ختام هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا
نذكر بابرز العناوين
المرصد يقول ان ضربه الاسرائيليه في حماه
وطرطوس استهدفت مستودعات سلاح لا تتبع
النظام
[تصفيق]
اسرائيل تعلن مقتل ثلاثه
امريكا تحذر من حرب استنزاف يشنها بوت
لارهاق الغرب وتحقيق النصر باوكرانيا
ويقول انه عرض عائلته للخطر خلال اقتحام
الكابيتول
[موسيقى]